هناك شيء مألوف للغاية
حول العودة إلى سنغافورة ،
وهي المدينة التي تستمر سمعتها في أي
وصول
بعد عامين من الإغلاق السري
، أعادت سنغافورة فتح نفسها
للعالم وفعلت ذلك بطريقة نموذجية
مع Vigor and Vim
على مر السنين كنت أذهب إلى
سنغافورة بانتظام  إنه مكان
رائع للترانزيت في مكان رائع لزيارته
في كتاباته الخاصة ، لكنني لم أذهب إلى
هنا خلال السنوات الأربع الماضية لأسباب واضحة ،
لذا فهذه فرصة رائعة
بالنسبة لي لإعادة الاتصال بصديق قديم
[موسيقى]
نظيفًا بالطبع  نزاع آمن من الأثرياء على
الإطلاق ، إنها واحدة من
أغنى دول العالم ، وإذا كانت سمعتها السابقة
ربما بقيت أجرؤ على القول إن
فيلم Crazy Rich Asians
دفع المال إلى أن
[موسيقى]
حصلت على فرصة
تعود بذور نجاح سنغافورة
إلى  القرن التاسع عشر
عندما كان السيد ستامفورد رافلز نعم ،
الذي سمي الفندق على اسمه ، أسس
المستعمرة كمركز تجاري استراتيجي
لشركة الهند الشرقية البريطانية.
نما مفترق طرق
وجذب الثقافات الهندية والماليزية الصينية
والأوروبية لأن ما
لديك هنا هو رجل من أصل هندي
له جذوره في باكستان قبل التقسيم مع
ممثل كوميدي هندي سنغافوري
ونحن في وسط الحي الصيني في
سنغافورة
ونحن نحاول صنع
خيوط من القطن المصري المصنوع في
بانكوك ، فإنه لا يصبح عالميًا أكثر مما
يمكن العثور عليه عادةً على خشبة المسرح من ريشي بوجواني ،
الجمهور ليس هنا ، لم
يتأخروا.  قبل ساعة من
كونه أحد أشهر الكوميديين في سنغافورة
اليوم ، كان مع
والده في متجر الخياطة التابع لوالده مثل أي
فيلم كوميدي كان لدي الكثير من القطع المستوحاة من
والدي ، تذكر أن بوب أرسل لي فاتورة
نعم
تعرف باسم جيمي لعملائه ريشي
نشأ أبي مع سنغافورة بعد أن
استقر هنا مع عائلته بعد
تقسيم الهند ، كان الأمر متخلفًا في ذلك الوقت ،
لكن الآن يمكنك أن ترى أنها أول
مدينة زجاجية الآن ، لقد كان خياطًا هنا
منذ السبعينيات من حقًا.  لقد أبقى والدي
الأطفال بعيدًا عن
العمل بنشاط كان كما تعلمون
، فأنا طبيب أصبح محامياً وأصبحت
مهندسًا وهنا أقوم
بإلقاء النكات على الأشخاص البيض المخمورين في
الحانات حول العالم ،
يجب أن تكونوا فخورين جدًا  هذا
نعم
، لقد سمعها والد ريشي قبل أن تكون
من سنغافورة ولدت وترعرع نعم 100
عندما اكتشف الناس أنني
كوميدي ستاند أب في سنغافورة ، هناك دائمًا
هذه الأسئلة مثل ما الذي حصلت عليه سنغافورة من
الكوميديا ​​وما اعتقدت أنه لا يمكنك  "
حتى لا تمضغ العلكة هناك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق
] منا نحن الذين يشبهون فير خارج المسار بصفته
ممثلًا كوميديًا في سنغافورة ، هل
يريد شخص ما ذلك ، نعم ، أنت خارج
الصندوق ولكنك في دائرة غير مرئية
ما زلت لا تريدها"  لا أعلم
أنه يتحدث عن قواعد سنغافورة
بشأن ما يمكن القيام به وأين
عندما انفصلت سنغافورة عن ماليزيا
وأصبحت مستقلة في عام 1965 ، كانت
صغيرة ، لذا كانت تحديات بناء
دولة مدينة عالمية المستوى هائلة.
es كانت عبارة عن استقرار القانون
والنظام وكان هناك خيط ذهبي
يمتد عبر النمو الاقتصادي
لمدينة منفتحة في تجارتها ، ويمكن أن تصبح
شائكة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالنقد ،
وأعتقد أن الكوميديا ​​الارتجالية هي واحدة
من آخر
معاقل حرية التعبير.  ليس فقط في
سنغافورة ولكني أعتقد أن أي مكان
في العالم يمنحني هذا النوع من
الحرية لأكون قادرًا على مشاركة أفكاري
المليئة بالفكاهة ، دعني أسمع أنك تصدر
بعض الضجيج
لا يرتكب الجميع خطأ التفكير في أن
ريشي متمرد إنه  تناقض
مثل الكثير ممن نشأوا هنا
مخلصون بشدة لثآليل سنغافورة
وكل ما أحبه هو المكان الذي تعيش فيه ، كما تعلمون
، أنا طفل من قلب الأراضي التي
نشأت فيها في هذا الحي الصغير الذي يسمى
بيدوك ، لقد لعبت كرة القدم تحت الكتلة
I  لقد طارد رجال الشرطة الأضواء المكسورة
، أشعر وكأنني أنا فقط
أكثر ما يعجبك في سنغافورة ،
في مكان ما بكلمة واحدة ، لن تكون هناك
كلمات سهلة على الرغم من أنني أفكر
في أنها مراهقة من سنغافورة
في الوقت الحالي ، من الأمور المزاجية الصغيرة التي
تعرفها عندما كنت مراهقًا أنك تريد
أن يكون والداك هناك بشكل واضح ولكن لا يتدخلان
كثيرًا في حياتك هو أن
الفرق بين كيف
ينظر إليه جيل الشباب مقابل
أجدادك أو والديك الذين كانوا
هنا عندما  البلد بدأ
جدي ذهب على متن سفينة لمدة سبعة
أيام واغتنموا فرصة في هذه
المدينة الصغيرة ، وكان هناك الكثير من
الناس مثل هؤلاء
الذين لم يكن لديهم ما يخسرونه ، أعتقد أن
الامتنان لأن هذا الجيل لا يزال لديه
شيء أه أصغر منه.  أنا
مثل من هم في العشرينات من العمر الآن لن
أكون قادرًا على الفهم أبدًا ، ومثل
أنني في الثلاثينيات من عمري ، أنظر إلى الأطفال اليوم
وسأذهب كما لو كنت لا تعرف مدى روعتك
، فأنت تعرف ما أنا  أنا أقول
ولا ينبغي أن أقول في وقتي إذا كنت
أبلغ من العمر 35 أو 38 عامًا ولكن ليس عليك إخبار الأشخاص
المهتمين بـ Beyond 35
ليبدأوا في اختيارك بشكل مختلف ، ما
الذي يعنيه هذا أنني أبلغ من العمر 60 عامًا.
ماذا يمكنك أن تفعل عرضك الخاص بشكل صحيح
حتى قال لا  أنا
[موسيقى]